The Joe Rogan experience.
Whereas like say a Chappelle,
if it was like,
you should go after like an hour.
Well,
you know,
he's got a very unique process.
Chip Chappelle does,
and he can turn over an hour like no one I've ever seen before.
And I was talking to Donna wrongs about it recently,
who,
you know,
was on the Chappelle show with him and he's like,
we both agreed like he's the best ever at turning over a new hour.
He could have a new way.
He could release a Netflix special and then have a new hour within a couple of
weeks.
He doesn't even make sense.
I don't,
I don't understand how he's doing it.
It must just floodings it's just,
he's in a great space.
You know,
he's in a great mindset to do comedy.
if,
if you pay attention to how,
you know,
when,
when people study,
like have you read outliers,
um,
and you read how people,
when people study,
why people are great at what they do and what makes them exceptional.
There's always a variety of factors and whatever the factors are with Dave,
he's got this easygoing personality,
this like very carefully carefree way of looking at things.
He's also gone through a lot of bullshit in his career with the leavings of the
Chappelle show and you know,
abandoning $50 million and going to Africa and really understanding what is real
motivation where he was caught up in that world where they were trying to change
him and commercialize his television show and he handled it as good as anybody
that's ever handled it.
He handled fame and temptation I think better than anyone I've ever heard of.
He just said,
fuck you.
And he just went away.
He went away and then didn't do gigs for years.
People don't understand.
He would show up and do standup places,
but he wouldn't book anything.
So like he wasn't getting paid.
He was just,
he did stand up.
Dave Chappelle did stand up in the park in Seattle.
He brought like a little amplifier and a microphone set up and just started
doing stand up and people just gathered round.
And he did this just to sort of get him back in touch with his roots.
Cause he used to do a lot of street performing in New York and I saw him do a
street performing in Montreal.
We did a club and then we came out of the club and Dave,
I think Dave was like 18 and 19 is a time just started doing stand up on the
street and put his hat out and people would put money in his hat.
I mean he was a constantly sharpening that sword and he stopped doing standup
for a long time in terms of like booking gigs.
And then after a while I said,
fuck it,
I'm gonna come back again.
And then he started doing these gigantic gigs.
And then of course he did his two recent,
uh,
Netflix specials were amongst his best work ever and you know,
and now he's,
he's working all the time.
He's constantly popping into the comedy store and the comedy cellar and all
these different clubs all across the country and constantly doing standup and no
social media.
He goes not not involved in any of that stuff.
It doesn't do anything just to just perform.
It's just does this stuff.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
When you,
it's like I,
I feel that some people have like found the essence and found
their path and live it like,
and like they know the light there.
A Yogi or a priest or something,
but he's just got a devotional.
This is who I am.
I'm not doing anything but it's not that.
And yeah,
that's exhibited even in earlier stuff prior to the crime that you know what you
were just,
you know,
the crisis of the 50 million walk away thing.
Like by then if he was 18 doing them clubs,
he was hardened.
Like what?
That,
what seems so loose on stage was something that had been refined as a person
who's comfortable and he was always good.
He was good when I first met him
when he was like 18 I think he was 18 I was 21 so it was somewhere in that
range.
Maybe I was a little older maybe who's a,
maybe it was like how old day?
46 47 I think he's five years younger than me.
Is that correct?
46 or 47 45 okay.
So He's more so six years,
six years younger than me.
So you know,
I was probably 25 and he was probably 18 ish,
25 26 1817 but he was um,
he was so like calm and like he was very like,
it was,
you were attracted to listening to him.
It was like,
like look at this guy.
Like this guy is like so comfortable in his own skin and so friendly and easy
going and hilarious.
But who he was then and then who he became is all the work that he put in.
You know,
it's like he had this base of this really,
you know,
this curious young,
very wise person who saw things that other people didn't see in the world.
And then he just kept going and just kept going.
And then of course the Chappelle show,
which is in my opinion,
the greatest sketch comedy show of all time,
even though it was only two seasons to the best ever.
And then after that,
I mean he's basically just on stand up and done it completely outside of the
system.
He's done some parts in movies and shit like that,
but for the most part what he's doing is just stand up completely outside of the
Hollywood system.
Completely free,
just goes up,
you know,
just to talk some shit.
How's a couple of drinks,
laughs and,
and,
and a,
and it's incredibly compelling.
He's found his groove,
you know,
and that's,
it's a beautiful thing to watch as a fellow standup comedy practitioner when
someone,
he it treat Cheves this mastery level,
like we,
you know,
we were talking about like this Hixon Gracie of standup comedy level because
that's where he's at,
right?
Yeah,
I agree with you.
Become who you are.
Yeah.
He's,
yeah,
he's become himself and he doesn't have things that are getting in the way of
that.
Yeah.
That's what's really interesting.
Like,
you don't see him.
He's like,
it's not on social media.
He's not on anything.
Twitter or Facebook is not on any of that shit.
He doesn't pay attention to any of it.
He's just just being a person,
just being a person and doing stand up.
You know,
it's a,
and he doesn't have to,
which is unique to,
you know,
he doesn't have to promote things.
They just sell out.
Well,
an amazing example,
or an amazing example.
I've got promote some things.
So what do you the book mentors.
Huh?
So I've really learned some powerful lessons there from the story that of a,
the apotheosis of comedy that Dave Chappelle's achieved.
Here's these obligations.
Yep.